let's see who else is up next why don't
we try the 903 area code caller from
9:03 introduce yourself tell us who you
are where you're calling and I'm from
the Denver area ring I'm sorry I was
calling to get your opinion because like
I'm a veteran alright and I went on a
deployment to Afghanistan and it changed
my whole outlook on like my politics the
military intervention ISM everything I I
know now that you know when I went there
or the war when I came back I was like
oh my god but I you know I've just kind
of lost here because I understand that
the reason why these wars go on is
because of the war profiteering
companies like General Dynamics Lockheed
Martin Raytheon I mean I thought to
myself and these companies you know they
go out there and you know with the
military completely pollute their
environment I mean it's crazy like in
her Air Force Base there's a there's
mountains of garbage mmm and it's awful
but I just I'm at a complete loss as to
how we can that such powerful
corporations you know from dictating our
policies so I was just want to know what
your thoughts from that listen to things
step one how do corporations get this
much power because of the campaign
finance system that allows them to
become influencers in government to
effectively own politicians who then do
their bidding for them so number one you
got to change the campaign finance
system if corporations weren't sources
of funding for politicians the way that
they are politicians would not be nearly
as incentivized to then do stuff for the
companies that allows them to have
effectively zero percent tax rates
offshore tax havens function in ways
that are completely extrajudicial when
it comes to you know the things when you
look at the focus on crime the focus is
mostly on street crime way after that
white-collar crime and way after that is
crime committed by crimes committed by
corporations who end up you know paying
some some meaningless symbolic fine so
number one you've got a completely upend
the campaign finance system number two
we need to elect people that will
actually hold corporations accountable
and the only way we're going to get
those people as prominent potential
elected officials is if you take away
the power of the corporation to be the
most attractive source of money for
elected officials so it all goes back to
campaign finance as far as the
military-industrial complex that's more
complicated because at this point we
know that for Republicans especially
anything but a constantly growing
defense budget and military budget is a
sign of weakness and that's like a
cultural issue and I don't know exactly
how you fix that but I think you do get
a lot of the problem but with campaign
finance corporations have this much
power because they're allowed to buy
this much power and we've got to take
that ability away from them okay I see
that that does sound like a very very
good solution very plausible yeah the
reason why this just gets me so much
David is that you know I have brothers
and sisters that go overseas all the
time and and they lose their lives and
they fight this endless war and I just I
can't help but feel like I'm out there
their lives are being wasted their lives
being exchanged for money and yes it is
sickening is the exact the exact word I
would apply to it
storm thank you thank you so much for
the call really appreciate it hope to
hear from you again